It is true, that using effects with viewport, means that
your content, is almost always going to be scaled, and not
match the native resolution. And definitely, in some cases, users
are going to have to zoom, to be able to see
or read anything, particularly text. Since, everything, all scaled depending
on the size of the screen, fitting the current layout, precisely,
into the users screen. Whether, it's a four inch phone
or a 12 inch tablet, but actually, your text in UI
will not change at all on the desktop. Because,
currently, at least, none mobile browsers, don't respond to
the view port at all. In some cases of
course, it's the right thing to do, if you
just want to get the UI to fit on the
screen, to use, fix with view port, like in
my sync app, but of course those dials are
awfully small, which makes the UI very hard to use.